today on the show ma'am we're gonna find
out who black panther answers to then we
gonna smoke some strange and with a
little bit of iron fisting all that and
a lot more men on the mostly Marvel
version of fat man our Batman
oh my lord I'm Kevin Smith mark barnard
all right man we're making it real we
told you we're gonna make a real on the
podcast we said we're gonna try to do it
as a show yeah there's a show there's
five six monitors dude you ain't kidding
there's cameras all that stuff I'm
sucking in my gut never normally do and
this is the most smoke free version of
this podcast we've probably ever done
normally I can't even see mark cause
it's so smoky or so lucid it's weird
yeah and that's led to a lot of
confusions like for example there's some
people watching this right now that are
just like they thought we were two white
guys I know it seems to be an enduring
myth but as you could say he's black yes
we are the ivory of geek talk ladies
gentle we have a lot to talk about we're
gonna break the show's down all week
long in tonight's 20 minute digestible
bites this section we're starting with
is all Marvel stuff man so let's hit the
news right off the top biggest biggest
news of the week I would say market has
everything to do with who's gonna direct
the Black Panther yes and you know we've
been talking a lot about Creed because
we do like the Creed didn't we also
fancy like didn't we wimzie like you
know it would be great
seriously and I think his name was
brought up I don't know if we were
talking about Black Panther but if you
go back to listen to one of the other
podcasts that we did about it I think we
were there before it happened we
certainly didn't give anybody any ideas
I'd say in that but yeah I have no it
was in the air I think it was in the air
but you saw Creed and I talked about
like this is the move dude I mean that
Ryan Coogler is who we're talking about
he's like he's got such a command of
both action and all the boxing stuff the
first the first fight you see with with
Adonis Creed in the ring against a
contender is all one take whoa oh really
yeah it's like a Birdman or touch of
evil everyone forgets it's a bird man
Orson Welles did it but yeah the idea of
one long track he pulls that pulls it
off like and in the ring which is like
there's fighting in the movie
but still some of this old timey boxing
but but black panther there's gonna be
there better be a lot of fighting we saw
in the civil war trailer there's at
least a lot of running fast totally yeah
it's the Tom Cruise school of special
effects
what's the committee's can run a lot you
guys that's his yeah Tom Cruise can run
like a [ __ ] I rewatched
JJ's mission impossible there's like one
long shot where he's like running and
charge or something like that along the
water for her where it's this he's like
a cartoon character but black panther
yeah yeah looks like he looks like he
runs it excels in a fashion faster than
cab Ryan Coogler is being rumored the
directors and negotiations with Marvel
about directing we all love this idea
you know we love this idea
to a point why because I do to a point I
sort of feel like there's there was a
world well in the 90s in which Ryan
Coogler would have come out with
Fruitvale station would have made Creed
and then have like I don't know seven or
eight more movies in them to find his
voice like you know as well as anybody
like a filmmaker takes time he's an
artist he's got to find his stride is
that what I should have done locked into
it it's like Carnegie Hall
but it's like if he was Spike Lee like
let's pretend he had that curry let's
pretending a really Scott's career or
it's I'm gonna make to-do list I wanna
make Barry Lyndon I'm gonna like do
these things that man Blade Runner comes
to their families then gladiator like I
tell you lost me in this conversation
when you said Spike Lee cuz now I'm
thinking of a spike Lee directed black
panther remember do the right thing yeah
yeah talkin out like but there's the
whole see pew sequence where they're
talking about the shoes and they're just
like black pit they're holding a black
panther comic book and like black
panther pizza weep it's a boy I love
does he Spike Lee do I mean it now I'm
crazy about that idea but still Ryan
coolers right and there's a path that
could have led Spike Lee there like post
Inside Man sorts like spike makes you
know the other day you change a
fantastic track and there was a
beautiful Widow I was listening that on
my Spotify and I was thinking like man
he
was in a commercial zone like only it
looked like he was spike was leaning
toward steven soderbergh world where
it's just like i'm gonna keep making
them one for me Batman
so you could pull this off we could've
totally but you know instead he made
chiraq witcher he was actually really
good but still ryan coogler Shrek you
know sure rack rack I went chiraq like
it's supposed to be like sure you're
like a rack right so she's rock shiraz
it's weird don't matter run the show
don't matter I'm funny
not until it comes it's at an Amazon
release right yeah this is the first
theatrical release actually talk about
fancy movies not have movie looks like
it might have a ryan coogler directing
block yeah like i just have faith that
it's gonna be good I just I I fear for
Ryan Coogler getting caught in the
Marvel machine mmm you know which if
we've learned anything from from Joss
Whedon's to movies is that he didn't
really like making those two movies I
could see concern but here's what I'll
counter with this was a man who only
four years ago with a buddy fanfiction
DUP Creed four years later he made it
happen people love it it's one of the
best reviewed movies of the year so he
seems to be a quick study um if he was
remotely interested in this material I'd
love to see him behind the camera I see
what you're saying like let him get a
few more some meat more meat on his
bones or some more work under his belt
but so far the work he's put out there
strong it knows what he's doing so I'd
say you know in a perfect world ya do a
bunch of stuff you can get to a comic
book movie but this is a better than
perfect world where we get a drink
redirected black panther and you're
sitting here going no I mean listen it's
I feel like it's gonna be a solid movie
I think he's a solid choice and I just
don't want him to lose the edges that
make him great well thought-out sir all
right let's it the next thing which is
also Black Panther related the Russo
brothers have confirmed that in Civil
War black panther never chooses a side
says here Black Panther is first of all
an amazing character we couldn't be more
excited to bring him to the screen for
the first time I believe this is Kevin
Feige saying this you
very sexual the store would know it's
one of the reserves duh
he's very central of the story he comes
into the story early what's great about
Black Panther in this movie is all the
characters choose aside Captain America
side or Ironman side black panther never
chooses size Switzerland
my name is Paul's between y'all oh my
lord what's that I've never heard of
they make cheese you say some of the
kids are like I understand that you're
absolutely right I mean that's the way
to play it right yeah I mean what
conda's got a standalone and you know
just please let that has got a
standalone I've read something online to
that maan Freeman who's in Civil War but
they haven't said who he's playing is
apparently Black Panther related like
it's a character second cousin yeah
apparently he I'm this could be wrong
and I've read a bit one of those
articles online where they're guessing
as well but I think he's the what condom
liaison who's United said yes and so he
figures they they put him in a civil war
because Chavez in a de chollet
but uh Everett Ross is that who it is
who's that he's the character so that's
how they think he's playing as Everett
Ross there we go really just look I'm a
little edgy that man never get that on
the old stone fat man or that man but
like facts coming in yeah good
information happening so apparently it's
rumored he might be playing Everett Ross
so he would play a bigger role than the
standalone Black Panther movie I saw
some people online theorizing that
Martin Freeman might be playing the Red
Skull which I was like why wouldn't they
go back we got one week eight have
already got a guy but that reminded me I
was like they still have to bring that
dude back they kind of tossed him and
you know in Captain America first
adventure they haven't really touched it
since but he's out there somewhere
how old is it rich I mean that touched a
little bit in Captain America Winter
Soldier
remember the
the big computer dude right I'm Zola I
love that I love that scene so much it
was so much out of like an old Bond
movie or spy movie or just like I'm
gonna tell you my whole evil plan and
the room is going to self-destruct and
he was a [ __ ] computer on old like
like the ColecoVision atom computer drop
is such a cool floor it reminds me that
that chunk in Raiders in Lost Ark where
it's literally we're gonna spend 10
minutes just laying story pipe what
happens the two FBI guys come in they
drop a big book on the table and they
just tell us the plot mmm and that's the
last time you have to stop for the plot
that's why I get a mark barnard and I'm
sure ladies and gentlemen go that
two-shot you know why because he'll a
story but first talks about writing in
the sexy it's long and lean how do you
feel about the Black Panther being
neutral makes sense it makes sense you
know I mean like his story they're
saying he's central to this story but
his story is movie yeah you know so like
it's true you shouldn't have to pick a
side yet especially yeah I don't know
like do you you wouldn't want that dude
coming in and going which white guy yeah
he's a white people problems
all right so dr. strange let's move on
to dr. strange yeah apparently there's
some dr. strange concept our this is for
reals for reals II reals
that's meant to be cumber be on Doctor
Strange the Magnificent that is wow man
all right there's your first look at
what could be Benedict Cumberbatch we
got 10 minutes left
Benedict Cumberbatch I mean this the
only wanders are another one they showed
some of this you don't make more there's
one there it is again look man they're
doing the Cape in the collar that's all
it matters
it's all about you give me the Cape
collar and the eye of agamotto I don't
care what words everybody wins they're
not gonna drop the ball I mean I've seen
reports where they keep saying like
Baron Zemo ain't gonna wear a mask in
the Civil War but I don't think it's
more important to anybody
beyond marvel I think it's the most
important Marvel I guess is what I'm
saying to have their characters look as
close to their characters as possible
historically if they've done a really
good job of it as you see in the civil
war trailer Falcons starting to look
like Falcon the colors they gettin is
there
yeah so you know maybe you get to a
place where where dr. strange you know
looks exactly like look because they
care so much they're not gonna put them
in jeans it's not gonna be like that
x-men line where it's like what do you
want us all in yellow spandex but I mean
look how far we've come from like the
only way you could make the x-men in
2000 and whatever that was was to put
them in black leather yeah like you know
post matrix pre matrix that matrix tone
you have to be in black and now the
audience now they're so like they the
audience owns them in such a way where
they're like here's apocalypse no it's
like no it's not no sorry no you jerk so
yeah they're listening in a big bad way
but that come on that's thrilling dude
yeah I grew up reading that [ __ ] like I
grew I put dr. strange in my daredevil
run you know it's talking to them Fisto
at one point it was gorgeous gorgeous
I've always loved that character and
they did a TV movie I can watch that
years ago cuz I was just like oh please
the idea of Steven strikes now they're
doing it on the big screen did and I'm
not like a comer [ __ ] holdout but I'm
not one of those people it's like
anything he does I think this is the
movie where he claims my soul max if you
nail this like when they just mentioned
it's Steven strange in Captain America
soldiers yeah just they said the name I
was this knocking off a bunch of like
listen this guy Steven strange whoa what
I rattled off was pre come out the tip
of my dick cuz I was like they just
acknowledged Steven strange there's a
lot more where that came from kids come
in any event that looks fantastic yeah
they should be showed a bunch of that at
d23 like you were there for that was
there tell the kids about it they
stitched together like a sir it was a
trailer is just lots of music over a
bunch of like concept art from Doctor
Strange and it was lush man real it was
just so beautiful like olive yeah I've
heard where did I did an episode of
movie fights yesterday is over screen
junkies and one of the movie fights
Dormammu was brought up and as we're as
a possible villain in a future Marvel
movie but word is Dormammu may be a part
of Doctor Strange if they get actual
civilians to say the word doorman
dude that's that is an epic win for
everybody
my mother goes Oh tiger did dr. strange
get Dormammu
that's terrorist can't win in a world
where we all know Dormammu is beyond us
boy that's yeah I look forward to that
and a big bad way are you strange guy
have you been I was never a huge strange
guy you know I sort of came to it a
little bit in the days a big stretch guy
yeah you loved him the strange it was
the the you can't wait to say yeah the
brain cave on come on we'll come on
Marco smart team miniseries introduce
yourself and tell them how much you come
on jump in come on be on this [ __ ] just
Tom Tommy telling the touchet oh I can
have am I looking here where you want to
dr. strange is my favorite hello first
oh I'm Mackey I produce I produce the
show is all the information how far back
you go strange he was one of my first
like 10 years old I was in love with dr.
strange no I'm 37 true can fit 30 seven
true confessions right there 27 years of
a love of yeah oh man it's the panache
it comes alive when they cast Cumbre
[ __ ] were you like that's the guy or
do did you have something else I was
actually hoping that they would get
Joaquin Phoenix I wasn't initially on
board for Joaquin but no ma'am I saw
what was it master and was like whole
you could do this oh he could do the
hell out of this but he fell away and
Benedict got it and Benedict it was my
initial one and but she's the one that's
still [ __ ] cold but I wanted dr.
Stephanie strange man cuz nobody's
[ __ ] stranger than till this one yeah
she would have killed him Andy Mads
Mikkelsen is confirmed to be in the film
but no one knows who he's playing was
got played Hannibal yeah what do you
guys think about him being drama if he
was dormant as long as his face is on
fire that's Dormammu the best
exactly thank you bring anybody back we
call it caulk and here's your moment but
you got to light your face on fire and
say your name a lot in the movie
Dormammu commands we went like this was
like a hike sending stickers all right
man what are we gonna go to next Ant Man
and the wasp we got 450 so we got 5
minutes left 10 so we could use the pace
let's talk about ant-man the wasp yeah
apparently you tell the story apparently
you know in the way that Captain America
Winter Soldier was kind of patterned
after those old 70s like conspiracy
thrillers you know three days in the
Condor days the Condor and they even
[ __ ] God Redford to come back for it
we have another genre template for a man
and wasp what is it they are keeping it
close to the vest they're being catty
about it being a little catty a little I
don't care as long as they bring in
Janet Van Dyne which I've heard two
names floated as possible
wasps and because Michael Douglas is
coming back yes and so they got to tell
that story that they told him flashback
in first ant-man they go looking for her
sub was it the sub atomic universe where
two names which like thrilled me the
first one was Catherine zeta-jones which
I thought was phenomenally sweet there
for those that don't know they're
married
so how sweet is that and everyone's like
what do you mean how would I not know
that grow up under a rock yes they're
married but so that would be kind of
sweet I know I don't know if they acted
together um I don't think they have
where they meet it's like an acting Club
or sensation I want to say that it was
like post mask of zorro which was her
big sort of stateside like la-dee-da
yeah there was some party that he was at
and saw her and did that like who is
that girl recently took a saber I was
like put an M on her shirt yeah she's
already been in a superhero movie Conan
Cesaro and the Phantom oh my god
excellent pole she was a band
yes the thing that she doesn't like to
admit she actually did the Phantom yeah
I mean I'm not a huge fan of the Lee
Falk character but there was respect for
it for the genre and whatnot and I
thought they did a fine job like in
terms of something that I had no
interest in saying like I walked out
gone that was pretty fun like where's
the shadow I was invested in sings I
loved that character and you know it
wasn't quite not what it could have been
yeah when when she was doing mask of
zorro press because I was a TW at the
time VW for those that don't knows
entertainment V Entertainment Weekly
marks job and they I totally am Playboy
Entertainment Weekly in Hollywood
Reporter I find all the wired yeah the
party line was from her publicity team
was that this was her stateside debut
mask of zorro get him out of here
between your resume she's like a trump
she's like maybe he needed to get better
get him out of here talk about my past
all right so that's one cool prospect of
Janet Van Dyne playing Catherine
zeta-jones the other equally is kind of
like I'm shall fight for hi aka our
Catwoman tell me I'll be back when we
were kids not in freak and half awake at
one pre yeah post Julie Newmar enter the
kid every free what's her name Halle
Berry yeah if that counts it's kind of a
little bit does but yes this this would
that's that's adorable so sweet and also
technically Marvel stealing somebody
from the DC stable kind of deep deep DC
stable in terms of like that's all DC
but I don't know in that weird
they still like to play you know we
don't like the direct competition I know
I'm stuff like that you know world would
they still play up the Marvel vs. DC
that is a tiny little movement as a tiny
little stick yeah and take your cat
wicked I mean and I wonder if the
had and they're going after is a little
bit of like screwball comedy maybe like
if they're gonna steal like preston
sturges or a little Billy Wilder in
there well then Peyton Rees the man for
the job that movie down with love you if
you did that - the songs that there's a
nice template nimi we rush that as a
wonderful movie all right man let's talk
about let's finish up what do you think
news of the week for those you know who
were interested in the Netflix series
over Marvel Marvel's Netflix series and
they've been crushing it we've talked
about on the podcast daredevil we're
getting something off their double on
the podcast
Jessica Jones we hate that out but we
talked about like hey man what what
where's Iron Fist where's Iron Fist as
Mark said there he is Danny Rand himself
man one of Marvel's old 70s favorites
part half of the Heroes for Hire team
we've already met Luke Cage yeah in in
Jessica Jones world so there were rumors
that like you know rumors like people on
the internet were writing stories like
Mabel maybe Marvel can't crack this code
particularly blah blah blah now they've
just announced what they got a
showrunner guy named Scott Buck who was
on Six Feet Under and Dexter just got
booked [ __ ] [ __ ] this I'm fisted I
assume he likes to [ __ ] yeah he's got it
most people do know you know he's alive
is amazing he came on the show and he's
arcing suing you because I don't like to
[ __ ] no Edwards a man of a sexual I know
that's why I get good jobs you can I
work I don't I'm indifferent to [ __ ]
so this guy's got the gig this guy's got
the gig you know but now the next
question 16 under 6 feet under in Dexter
all right well they pulled the
showrunner for Jessica Jones she also
was on Dexter's oh so Dexter and she
wrote the 12 that Dexter that Dexter
benches deep it's not people pulling
from it yeah yeah Marvel particularly
Marvel seems to like like you know well
thought about it Dexter was a superhero
show it's kind of Batman without a mask
and he just killed worth killing [ __ ]
this is killing not joking yeah Stan
might have done something already so but
he stabbed a plastic everywhere
I could kill him and the blood can flow
or the jism could go arcing and stuff
no I it was definitely it seems like
that's a show you could pull easily from
because they already know how to do
episodic they already know how to do
ongoing mythology history and they know
how to do Chandra genre and and it was
kind of comic book without being called
superhero without being super I should
say yes another big question that's kind
of rolling on the internet is who's
gonna be iron fist Danny ran Danny ran
now in the comics Danny ran Caucasian
yeah white guy because in the grand
tradition of comics and you know
imperialism colonialism it had always
been and it's gone on since the shadow
basically white guy goes to n Asian
country learns a bunch of [ __ ] learns it
better than the Asian people do bring it
back to the states and fights crime with
it I look I could go some of that but
the learns it better than we know it
somehow yeah we teach him but he's
somehow it's for bass yeah yeah so it's
the Doctor Strange its shadow it's
Batman yeah yeah it's it's the thing
that happens and there is a good sense
that maybe this could be a corrective to
that there's a way to cast an Asian
American to play Danny ran and still get
kind of the best of both worlds you know
and you get to tell the story that
Marvel hasn't told you yet which is odd
given that it's set in New York which is
the immigrant story to see like let's
let's build that texture of New York
let's talk about a third generation
asian-american maybe even biracial if
you still want to keep the randfamily
line as it goes down if you ever want to
do the Seven Cities of heaven Tournament
that the fraction and then Prue Baker
did you can still have all that but also
tell the story of a guy who's caught
between two worlds of a guy who is torn
between his Asian heritage and American
heritage and is torn between not fitting
in in a place where you've seen as a
foreigner given the world we're in right
now where we apparently love Muslims but
don't want to have them in the country
talking about what it's like to be an
American but still be foreign while
being on the soil like just I want to
watch that good like that's it that's a
nice undercurrent to a show where he's
like any punches people in the face with
a magical fish
you know maybe that smart man why not do
that that would seem to be the smart
from a purely business perspective given
that we're in a world in which we are
setting movies in China we are
incorporating Chinese characters that
don't ever appear in the original source
material because China will pay for
stuff because China has the biggest
single market of like emerging
moviegoers and and pop culture watchers
why not why wouldn't you do that it's
smart call you know is there anyone is
there word of any kind out there is
anybody heard anything you know there
have been some casting rumors going on
there's a couple of reporters who are
digging into stuff here and there but
trying to find out who's already met for
it okay and at one point that we're
Asian actors who sat down to talk about
it but nobody knows of anybody's pull
the trigger quickly before we jump out
of here casted who would who would you
go for I mean for me it's you know given
that there is no bench of Asian actors
who are like you know there's an Asian
actor you gonna put it in aside from
like you know the guy from walking dead
who seems to still have a job for now
you know it's like slew seals coming
that's all I'm saying
find somebody new find McVicker star
cast around him like you know build up
that supporting cast make them fabulous
but nobody knew Charlie Cox was really
before daredevil like Marvel is your
star Marvel is why people show up so you
don't need a face did you hear that go
that to shut this is why it because why
you team up with a mark barnard man and
drink that as well smart sniper in the
room that's it man we wrap up all the
Marvel news for this portion of fat man
on Batman come later in the week and
we'll do the DC portion and then the
third portion will be everything else
which of course includes Star Wars and
one night but for those who are like
we're about the podcast podcast will
still exist don't worry about that go to
SModcast comm that'll always be there
subscribe to this channel if you want to
keep watching this get the alerts and
you let them know when the show come up
and whatnot YouTube / Kevin Smith I
believe is the title and whatnot hey
thanks the good folks at the fine media
who put all this together
not pretty look at this this is crazy
you're gonna dopey dream and suddenly
you're there and
and follow mark barnard and at mark
barnard in' i'm at that kevin smith come
back and i guess in a couple days yes
nobody was every other day or something
like that further the d c-- stuff man
come back to our fat cave same fat time
same fat channel SModcast won't we don't
tell anymore
YouTube's ice Kevin Smith
hey thanks for watching fat man on
Batman turkeys you want to see more of
this subscribe to my channel click below
tell your friends join us in the fat
cave all sizes welcome all are welcome
crossover children all are welcome